how the ultr rich get rich and avoid
taxes legally and if you don't know who
I am my name is Alex rosi I got my first
$100 million by age 32 and I did that by
taking $42 million in distributions from
my first big company gym launch and I
ended up selling that company for 46.2
million I reinvested that 42 million in
distributions into portfolio of
companies that's today at acquisition.
comom just over $200 million a year and
so that's my evidence to why I have
something worth saying about this now
that being said I'm going to split this
video into two parts one is the four
strategies that the ultr rich use in
order to get wealthy and then the second
half I'm going to explain how you can
use those same four strategies to
reverse engineer a $10 million goal and
the reason I use $1 million as the net
worth goal is because $10 million at
four or 5% per year which would be
basically a RIS risk-free investment
strategy you'd be able to live like the
top 1% in today's market so you could
move these dollars up as dollars get uh
inflated and all that kind of stuff but
for now these are the big four
strategies and so these developed over
time as my understanding of money
improved and so for me I now want to
make a billion dollars or at least be
worth a billion
dollars haha lots of zeros okay so the
first version of this that I thought in
order for me to be worth a billion
dollars was to make
1.5 billion dollars I know a lot of zero
in income all
right because after taxes which would be
67% taxes in the US which is the highest
federal tax rate that you can that you
have to pay you'd be left with $1
billion overall post tax okay that's the
zero leverage version of making money so
this is just income Generation all right
V2 of this is thinking okay well if I
make a billion dollars or I make income
every year I'm going to invest a certain
percentage of that income into making
money for me passively and so this feels
harder than making $100
million per year and reinvesting that
money at 9% so the Clear Point here is
I'm just saying this is just the S&P
this is just the market this isn't doing
anything fancy you're just buying
indexes of the S&P 500 now at $100
million a year in 10
years you would make $1 billion now
that's because this post taxes uh you'd
have
600 and sorry $67 million post tax
income that you then invest at that same
9% which would get you your billion
dollars after a decade you're like okay
well making $100 billion a year in
income versus making $ 1.5 billion in
income over however long period of time
this feels a little easier because now
I'm giving two things I'm generating
income
plus I'm using public equities all right
so I'm I'm using passive investment
strategies for things that are ready
available to the public for everyone the
V3 version of this it gets spicier and
spicier every time is that you do you
make $1100
million per year and you own the asset
you own the business that makes this
much money and you sell
it at call it 12x when I say 12x means
12 times earnings which a company of
this size it' probably be fair that it
would get that kind of multiple because
it's so big which means that you would
make 1.2
billion which would leave you post tax
with around $1 billion now what people
don't talk about this as a total side
note and as somebody who sold multiple
companies is that everyone has this big
dream to sell a company and get the
check but what they don't tell you is
that you then have a check and then you
have to do something with the check so
now you have to translate that check
back into equities so you just sold
equities and you get money and then you
have to buy equities yet again
and so then you have to think to
yourself am I going to get a better
return on this billion dollars than I do
within the existing business or asset
that I ended up selling and I'm going to
translate these zeros down to the $10
million goal that we're talking about in
a second but I just like to show what it
looks like at scale so that this can
just so you can see how the Big ultr
Rich stuff actually happens in the real
world now this is the the V3 version
this is income so that's the skill plus
private Equity all right so this was
public Equity this is priv private
Equity all right so a little bit
different this business isn't available
on the market there's institutional
buyers who raise funds and then they
will give you a check for the business
that's V3 of this now V4 of this is very
sexy and has three different sub
strategies all right and so in this
instance you have your business that
makes $100 million per
year and so you choose one of three
paths path one so we'll go a we'll go B
and we'll go C
so at the top level you can do something
called an
ESOP an ESOP is an employee stock
ownership plan where you sell between
33 and 49% mind you this is a minority
stake in your business and a bank will
finance your employees back stopping
that debt with the equity that you sell
them employees get the equity here bank
is here and then there's you and so the
bank gives you money and lends it to the
employees to pay you using the stock
that you gave them as collateral now
what's interesting about this at least
in the United States and I'm sure
there's different functions like this
internationally is that this payment at
least in our tax laws is taxfree and so
you get a smaller multiple because banks
will always pay less because they have
to think about risk not upside then
potentially a private Equity buyer would
but this is taxfree to the owner which
is pretty sweet now one of the other
nice things here is that you still
maintain control of your business
because you still own majority and so if
you do it in this way you can help your
employees get wealthy you get a taxfree
check uh they get to participate in the
growth of the business and often times
esops can go well because then now you
have a huge team of people who are also
incentivizing growing the business and
quote act like owners but they didn't
need to come up with the money it's like
here's your stock and then they go
straight to the bank and then the bank
gives them the loan to pay you for the
stock you gave them it's kind of how it
works okay that's version a of this now
the way this works though is that you
just traded the equity and you get cash
for what you gave the employees but you
still own the asset and so the asset is
still worth what it is in the private
realm so if you add those two things
together you still have a billion dollar
but you get the liquidity and you keep
the control the version B of this is
something called a dividend
recap so dividend recap is using the
same bank structure that you'd have with
an ESOP except you just cut the
employees out of it you just go directly
to the bank and say hey how much will
you loan me using my entire business as
collateral now if you think huh that's
weird think about it like buying a house
if you buy a house you go to the bank
you put x% down and they give you debt
for the rest of it and then you pay that
debt off and so the business actually
works the same way so if you have no
debt on the business or even if you do
have debt on the business you go and say
hey we can reliably produce this much
income and so we could pay off this
level of debt and so then a bank would
say okay well we'll give you four times
or five times your total eida or your
earnings for the year roughly and will
give you that as debt so if I make $100
million a year they might give me a $500
million loan that they know that my
business will be able to pay the
interest off on which for them makes
sense because they're just getting paid
to give money that they that they loaned
out right and then you have terms
associated with that debt right now if
your business is growing then it makes a
ton of sense to do that you drisk a
little bit as an owner and the key Point
here is that the business carries the
debt not you personally and so you as a
person the owner of the business gets to
take the $500 million but the business
pays the debt off and so let's say 5
years later maybe the business pays all
of the debt off you got the $500 million
and you still own the business just like
owning a house at the end of paying it
off works the same way kind of cool now
the third version of this is one that
people are a little bit more familiar
with which we kind of used earlier which
is public equities meaning you go public
with the company that you have and so
now when you go public you only have to
sell a small percentage of shares in
order to make them available to the
public and by doing that the remainder
of the stock that you have starts to
have an actual Marketplace value and so
the value of this and one this is one of
the biggest benefits of going public is
that you don't have to sell 33 to 49% of
your shares you could sell 10% or 5% of
your shares and then the other 95% has a
market value in real time and so then
you can still go to those same
institutions Banks Etc and say Hey I
want you to loan me and the thing is is
here you can do it peace meal you don't
have to go through a six-month process
or 12month process to get one specific
amount you can say hey lend me uh 5
million a day lend me 20 million
tomorrow lend me you know 100 million on
this other day and you can do that
process in 24 hours because you have
equities that are publicly available
which they can collateralize meaning
they can then take that if for whatever
reason you don't sell and so most of the
times banks will loan up to 50% of the
value of the stock that you have and so
if I have a billion dollars in stock I
can get a loan up to $5500 million and
so this is exactly what Elon did when he
went to go to go buy to buy X he just
took a loan out of his wallet and then
just bought it in cash kind of cool
right and so the idea here is that these
are three different ways that you can
use and you're like okay well then
what's the meta strategy for V4 V4 is
you have an income producing thing plus
you understand debt because all three of
these strategies use a bank or an
institution to front the capital and the
main thing with all three of these is
that you actually retain ownership and
control and so as my understanding of
money and markets Improv approved I
started to understand different ways
that I could achieve my billion dollar
goal now if you're like okay Alex that
sounds great but you said there was
something about the ultr rich and
avoiding taxes well let's talk about the
taxes and let's translate it to the $10
million goal okay so here this is
taxfree pretty nice with the ESOP thing
the dividend recap also the uh this
isn't taxfree because you have to take
it as a as a as a payment right so that
one you still have to pay taxes on here
it's taxfree because it's it's a loan
against your public equities part of me
feels like dividend recap might be
taxfree not sure on this but the uh
public equities absolutely the loans
that you take against them are tax-free
because they're loans and you pay
interest on them and then you have to
pay loans back and that's the big thing
and there's a big you know I would say a
little bit of a misconception on this
it's like oh these rich people uh they
should be paying tax on unrealized gains
well until someone gets money for
something I think that it's like having
someone pay income tax on a paycheck
they haven't gotten yet I feel like
that's a little bit ridiculous on the
other hand with the public equities
peace you still have covenants that you
have to be responsible for to whoever
gives you the money and so it's not like
you get the money and you can do
whatever you want with it you have to
pay it back that's how loans work now
the only way that this works longterm is
that your business continues to grow if
the business goes down then you're in
deep so you can lose it all and so
there's risk that's not being
appropriately valued when people say oh
these rich people just take loans off
their stuff but this is fundamentally
how you can do it and get liquidity or
cash from something that you own that's
valuable okay now if you're like all
right Alex that sounds fantastic but I'm
not trying to make a billion dollars
right now I'm trying to get to $10
million over the span of my life ideally
as fast as possible in net worth and the
reason I use $10 million is that because
at 5% you can make about 500,000 a year
at least in the US which would be about
the top 1% in terms of earnings pretty
sweet now as a side note this you also
pay less taxes on so this is usually
going to be something called qualified
dividends meaning you only pay 20% on
this rather than paying income tax so
you actually get more for your money
when it's off of passive distributions
Okay cool so if we're using these four
strategies here V1 of this is just the
pure income method which means that over
the span of your life you're going to
need to make $15 million in income and
then after your 67% tax rate you'll be
left with 10 million bucks okay that's
V1 not a lot leverage but you can do it
that way the V2 version of
this is that you make your $1 million
per
year per year oops there we go $1
million per year and you make and you
still pay your taxes on that but you
invest that post
tax at
9% and then after 10 years you have $10
million so a total interesting side note
on this is that with 10 years then at 9%
and given the the tax rate that exists
in the US is that on a 10-year time
Horizon you can measure how good someone
is at investing their money based on
what their value of their portfolio is
10 years later relative to what their
income would have been untaxed and so if
I made a millionar a year in 10 years I
should have $10 million if I paid zero
taxes but since I pay 37% taxes or
anybody who would make this would pay
37% taxes then every year they're
actually making $670,000 and so if you
invested that 670 at 9% then you'd make
at the end of that period $10 million so
you'd actually be back where you started
because you had to invest to make up the
difference in taxes and obviously the
first year of that 10 is significantly
more valuable because of compounding
than the last year of that 10 I'm
keeping this simple and not getting into
living expenses and things like that
which obviously would complicate this
okay so that is income income plus
passive investing income Plus
active investing so V3 of this is that
you make $1.2 million per year from an
asset meaning you own a business that
let's say it does $10 million in revenue
and it does $1.2 million in
distributions or owner earnings all
right and let's say that you can sell
this thing at uh 10x all right so less
than the company over here but the only
way you'd be able to sell a company at
this value which you can at this size uh
reasonably you know if it's a business
that truly is an asset so right now
there's HVAC companies that are selling
at 10 12 14x there's dental offices
there's accounting firms so these are
real businesses that can be sold if
you're in the right Market again I'm
going to use Simple illustrations here
so this would then give us $12 million
that you would get pre-tax and then you
pay your capital gains taxes that you'd
have to pay within the US which would
leave you with 10 million bucks now
again same as before okay I have this
thing that was passively making me $1.2
million a year $100,000 a month well
what am I going to buy with my $10
million that's going to replace this
thing sometimes thinking the Second Step
Ahead can influence whether or not you
want to sell this overall but I do like
to make the point so this one is income
plus our active or private Equity so we
had public
here we had private here and then V4 is
going to look a little bit different
because we have this $10 million goal
and so I want to tell you a different
strategy that I think is wildly
underrated which is you can go and
become an
employee at a company or a partner
depending on how you want to see this of
a
company that then goes public for a
billion dollars that you own 1% of and
that you earned over five years and
what's cool about this particular path
is that you get all the benefits of this
path over here is that you can take
loans against the stocks that you have
that are worth 1% and you too can live
like the ultra rich and take those those
loans taxfree now you can't do an ESOP
because you're you're not the owner of
the business but you can do in my
opinion the most attractive of the three
of these things which is that you can
have in real time access to liquidity or
cash to buy the things that you need
based on the value of the asset you have
and so let's say that you uh you start
working in a business they say we'll
give you 0. 2% per year times 5 years
and you do the five years and the over
that time period the company goes public
for a billion dollars da one billion
well you get the idea then your stock is
worth $10 million but here's the nice
part is that you paid probably a very
very very gracious tax amount to get
this or these options Associated um with
the shares and then you have something
that is worth $10 million that you can
then take loans against all right so
these are the four strategies from the
ultrich translated into normal income
goals now I want to zoom out for a
second because I think this will be
helpful for everyone no matter which of
these paths you choose or the versions
of the past that you want you'll notice
some common themes the first one is that
you have to be valuable
like you have to learn how to provide
value to the marketplace either as an
employee or as a small business owner or
as a larger business owner overall but
either way you have to learn how to
generate income and the way you generate
income is by solving problems for other
people and learning skills and so a lot
of time I see dedicated to content from
people who don't talk about the most
important thing which is sure you can
have all these passive investment
strategies but if you're working off of
$35,000 a year it's never going to
happen like we like to talk about the
one lady who worked at McDonald's for 50
years and saved every penny she ever had
so she could end up with a million
dollars but is that really the ideal
strategy when maybe taking a weekend and
getting a certification can bump you to
50 or $60,000 a year or you just learn
outbound sales and you bump yourself to
$150,000 a year five times the earning
potential and so I think that the
investing stuff gets really sexy because
it feels passive but you live your whole
life and so you might as well get five
times 10 times more for the time you are
guaranteed to have to give we all spend
seconds every second we're alive and so
you might as well get more for them the
second one is what I want to talk about
is the fallacy or the three fallacies of
Warren Buffett so Warren Buffett a lot
of people like I just want to do what
Warren Buffett did he just slowly
invested right well let me walk you
through what the fallacies of Warren
Buffett
are so three
fallacies of Warren Buffett number one
I'm going to be just like him well did
you buy your first at age
seven and did you do that weeks after
Pearl
Harbor when there was literal blood in
the streets well if you didn't buy your
first stock at age seven literal weeks
after Pearl Harbor then maybe you don't
already have the makeup of somebody
who's going to be the greatest investor
of all time something to consider the
second is are you going to live through
the greatest growth in American history
as you start your investing career which
is exactly what Warren Buffett was able
to do and the third one is one that I
actually talk about that I don't hear
talked about a lot which is just luck
and so let me hear me out I think Warren
is brilliant and I talk about him all
the time and I think there's a lot of
things we can learn from him but what I
see when I look at the top 0.1% whatever
the top of the top of the top of the top
is that you have all the skills all the
traits all the everything comma and luck
because the only way like if you were to
think of the hypothetical the the number
one person on Earth in general would
have all of the things plus luck because
some everyone's going there is luck that
goes around and so the number one person
is going to have everything that's
required plus luck there's plenty of
investors that are brilliant investors
that are worth $1 billion instead of
$100 billion they just didn't get the
luck part right or they've been only
investing for 30 years instead of 70
right or 75 for 85 or whatever the
amount of years he's alive now all right
and so I think these three things are
some are things that are not considered
when people like oh I want to do the
strategy and I want to highlight this
because the main theme of all of these
is that you have to generate income you
have to make money it's the only way you
can even have the income so like right
now I have a handful of Investments that
are doing exceptionally well but the
only reason that I would be able to make
those Investments is because I have
excess capacity in terms of cash Capital
that I could deploy if you don't and
this is where like living below your
means to make more so you have the Delta
so you can can you can get aggressive is
so important and I think it's really
lost in the narrative today and so the
last thing I want to talk about is what
Rich parents give as the greatest gift
to their kids and so the number one
predictor of success longterm is the zip
code you're born in all right and I find
that really interesting and also
disparaging in some ways because it
means that it controls for IQ it
controls for ethnicity controls for
gender it's the ZIP code that you're
born in and I see that as mostly due to
the association conditions of other
people in that zip code and so it's like
okay that means that conditions can
create our Behavior or shape our
Behavior so then what Behavior changes
happen in a rich environment versus a
poor environment and I think that it can
really come down to one main thing which
is the leverage of the opportunity
vehicles that you pursue and so I
remember this clear as day because I I
came from what I would consider upper
middle class so my dad's a doctor um but
when I went to Vanderbilt I was exposed
to an entirely different level of wealth
that I didn't even really knew existed
I'm from Baltimore there just wasn't any
like New York money like it wasn't
really a thing like if like it just it
was a concept I didn't understand but
for them the opportunity
vehicle that they wanted their kids to
pursue had leverage meaning they got
more for what they put in and so a
middle class parent might say hey you're
a Salesman awesome and you sell cars
okay well you sell cars and cars cost
whatever and the top top top cars SM
salesman might make you know 300 to
400,000 a year okay now some people are
like there's this one guy cool well good
for him but for most like let's call it
top 1% are making $3 to $400,000 a year
now the upper class salesmen or the
upper class or the ultra Rich whatever
you want to call it Ultra
salesman sells
companies and guess what he makes 4% on
the deal and so if he sells a $200
million
company he makes 8 million bucks for one
sale and so same fundamental skills
obviously there a little bit more
analysis here but fundamentally you are
selling stuff and all somebody who is
wealthier does is tries to get more for
what they put in they try and add zeros
to the price tag of the things they sell
if you sell a $500 million building you
get a commission for that just like you
get for selling a $50,000 house same
concept you just add scale to it and
every one of these people has the same
number of hours per day which just means
they get more for their time and so
thinking through this what poor people
or middle class people miss that rich
people or Rich Kids Rich parents pass to
their kids is which opportunities to say
no
to they don't even
consider the quote lower class or middle
class opportunity and I think of this on
something that I like to refer to is
measuring
sticks and so I'll give you a little
story to illustrate the point so when I
was a kid
in high school I worked I started my
first job when I was 15 and N months
which was like the legal age that I
could start working I started working as
a blender tender at Smoothie King and as
I as I leveled up and became a lead and
then I think a manager at some point and
then eventually I shifted to catering uh
which I got 25 bucks an hour for which
was awesome back in my day anyways I was
hoodrich and the thing is is that I
measured how much money I had and how
many Chipotle burritos I could buy
because I knew that Chipotle Burritos
were about seven bucks and so so I was
like man I just got you know 200 bucks
for this shift that's like 28 burritos
that I can buy now which is awesome
right I was super excited about it and
so what happens is the measuring stick
that you use to measure stuff the
wealthiest people in the world just have
a larger stick in two ways one is they
measure over longer time Horizons and
they also use like they literally call
by the way in Wall Street a stick is $1
million so that's the slang among rich
people like if you're like oh I didn't
know that there was slang for a million
dollars there is slang for a million
dollars when you have lots of millions
of dollars you say give him two sticks
it means two million bucks and so when
you hang around people who talk in
increments of $1 million imagine the
opportunities that they're pursuing and
more importantly for everybody who's
listening to this the many things they
say no to and so this is where you lose
years and Decades of life is that you
say yes to opportunities that you
otherwise shouldn't and so they're able
to be patient or more selective because
they know that they're going to get they
want to maximize how many dollars they
get out for the effort and time they put
in and unless something is going to
ladder up to remember we're thinking
longer time Horizons something where
they can get sticks for their time then
they're not going to do it they're
willing to take a job for 50 or $60,000
a year or $80,000 a year as an analyst
at you know PWC oron young or McKenzie
or an investment Bank League Goldman
Sachs they're willing to eat dog
for that period of time because they
know that that's not the plan this is
just the period that they're learning
and gaining experience so that they can
do the next thing they see it in
stepping stones and the vast majority in
my opinion of people who stay stuck
don't have a plan they don't see where
things lad are up to and they don't
reverse their goal into the present and
so no matter what whichever of these
paths you use one you have to focus on
income generation and learning skills
two you want to make sure that you
actually say no to the things that don't
matter and be very selective about the
things that will give you the highest
return three surround yourself with
people who have bigger measuring sticks
in terms of time and money than you
because whatever opportunities they're
discussing will likely be higher
leverage the opportunities that you're
considering and then finally in with
regards to the fallacy of of Warren
Buffett if you want to make obscene
amounts of money you will not make it
the way that someone else has already
made it it will be made in a new way
which means the single greatest and most
valuable skill that a human being can
have is the ability to come to their own
conclusion and have the confidence to
act on it despite it being contrary to
what other people are doing because if
it's what everyone else is doing then
it's not an opportunity because the
funny thing about opportunity is is they
look like Risk while they're
opportunities and the moment they're no
longer risky is when the opportunity has
closed and that's how life works you
have to make bets and you want to make
the bets that you feel like you have an
information advantage over other people
so you can come to your own conclusion
rather than listening to other people
have an amazing day hope you enjoyed
this stuff that's how the all Church do
it and if you you like these kind of
deeper business Concepts I have two two
free gifts for you I wrote $100 million
offers and $100 million leads these are
both available for free on my podcast
which is the game Alex Rosa you can just
search my name you'll probably find it I
also have these in course if you like
watching rather than listening uh on my
site at acquisition. comom you can just
click training and you'll see the
courses that we available they're all
free um but if you do like something
hard you can grab these wherever you buy
books and uh hopefully make a lot more
money